hola
bueno estoy aquí porque
tengo una forma de ver la vida no sé si
esa forma es la correcta pero a mí me
funciona mucho y quiero compartirla
a lo largo de mi vida han pasado
muchísimas cosas
estoy actor ahora soy conductor fui
futbolista
fui lavador de carros vendía desayunos a
domicilio vendía flores
repartía hamburguesas al carbón en
bicicleta y hacía tantas cosas y tantas
cosas tuvieron que ver con mi vida que
pues de alguna forma eso complicaba más
escoger un tema y saber de qué hablar
pero él sí ya lo había dicho y esa era
mi mejor motivación para estar aquí con
ustedes
entonces decidí hacer algo que para mí
es fundamental que es muy sencillo de
alguna forma y que pocas personas lo
hacen y las las que lo hacen de pronto
no lo desarrollan de la manera más
adecuada
y eso es escucharse
porque digo que no de la forma más
adecuada a veces queremos encontrar las
respuestas y a veces queremos
escucharnos en el mismo punto
de la problemática queremos en ese
círculo de tensión que nos lleguen las
ideas que nos llegue la respuesta saber
qué es lo que tengo que hacer y no
hacemos algo tan sencillo como salirnos
de ese espacio
respirar
y tratar de verlo desde afuera y tratar
de entender qué es lo que necesito para
encontrar una solución
cuando te escuchas
te encuentras encuentras toda esa gama
de colores encuentras los de medio los
más brillantes los más oscuros y también
creo que por eso es difícil escucharse
porque si de pronto encuentras esas
cosas brillantes de tu vida esas cosas
que podrías lograr pues esas eso
requiere una responsabilidad requiere
una atención y pues que le eches un ojo
y entonces es un tanto complicado y
mejor huimos de eso y lo dejamos atrás o
si vemos esos colores más oscuros y nos
escuchamos encontramos a demonios muy
fuertes todos esos rasgos de
personalidad que no nos gustan de
nosotros mismos
con los cuales no nos sentimos cómodos
pero también para eliminarlos de
nuestras vidas tendríamos que
escucharnos y hacer algo para que ellos
se fueran entonces entiendo que todo eso
es bastante difícil
damos carpetazo y queremos vivir la vida
por en medio de pronto y a mi planeta la
vida por el medio creo que no siempre es
es muy chica
entonces decidí escucharle decir
escucharme y no hice lo que acabo de
explicar no me senté en una computadora
con un café en mano a eduardo que te
lluvia de ideas tienes que escribir algo
interesante tienes que hablar algo más
científico de tu carrera como psicólogo
tienes que hablar algo de la actuación
no no forcé mi mente
mejor busque un espacio de introspección
que a mí me funciona mucho y que creo
que a muchas personas también les
funciona para escucharme y pensar
entonces me metí a bañar
todos los días yo amo la música es una
guía en mi vida todos los días me
levanto y lo primero que pienso es qué
canción va a ser la que inició mi día
esa misma canción es con la que me baño
esa canción tiene que durar dentro de
tres y cuatro minutos porque en ese
espacio me tengo que bañar sí o sí para
ahorrar agua y ayudarle al planeta
puse la canción mientras la estaba
escuchando me estaba bañando y empezaron
a llegar las ideas
pero también lo más chido de todo esto
es que ni siquiera llegaron tantas ideas
sino que llegó la idea que tenía que
presentarse y más que idea es un
concepto
la felicidad
con esto llegó una frase que un día
escuché de un actor de mi película
favorita
le dijo a un reportero y la frase era
ésta
tú necesitas ser feliz para vivir yo no
esta frase la dijo qian reeves la dijo
en un momento muy difícil de su vida lo
estaba presionando entiendo un poco
porque lo dijo pero la frase la frase es
muy verdadera y tenía un gran punto
porque creo que no necesitamos ser
felices para vivir
no necesita ser feliz para levantarte
todos los días e irte a trabajar no
necesitas ser feliz para comer y estar
saludable
no necesitas ser feliz tampoco para
para respirar y va a tenerte en esta
vida
o sea fue algo muy fuerte en mi vida
porque
es algo por lo que yo he luchado en
contra toda mi vida desde que soy
chiquito siempre trato de hacer un
ambiente alegre a dónde voy con las
personas que hablo la felicidad es
fundamental entonces cuando escuché eso
dije no puede ser
entonces evidentemente esta frase fue
muy complicada fue muy fuerte y más
porque yo desde pequeñito como les decía
he buscado la felicidad y siento que
todo es más chido si estás feliz
cuando cuando éramos niños
todos pasamos por momentos muy difíciles
unos momentos más difíciles que otros
pero creo que todos esos momentos nos
definieron como personas todos los
momentos que pasé en mi vida
ahora este es el resultado esta persona
que está platicando con ustedes y
respecto a esto me gustaría abrir un
paréntesis y decir que creo que el dolor
es completamente personal cada quien
tiene sus luchas cada quien tiene sus
dolores y no podríamos comparar los
dolores de nadie
y ha dicho esto mi infancia hubo muchas
cosas hubo muchos momentos muy
complicados
a veces uno no se imagina que pueden
suceder pero los que creo que más
fueron los más importantes y los que
formaron esta persona fue que tuve
ciertos descuidos tuve como un niño
abandonado con falta de atención
y sobre todo creo que pues faltó un poco
de amor
todo esto bastante cool porque esto fue
lo que me formó y lo que me enseñó desde
chiquito que sí o sí para ser feliz
tenía que aprender a adaptarme
hay una una historia muy chistosa que me
pasó cuando tenía como siete u ocho años
en esta situación de que mis papás pues
no podían estar conmigo porque tenían
que hacer sus cosas contrataron a una
señora para que me diera de comer esa
era su única labor
mi mamá dejaba ahí para que prepararan
unas milanesas las milanesas en el
platillo favorito entonces la labor de
esta señora era darme de comer para mi
mala suerte
en ese entonces la señora que me cuidaba
era un tanto gordita y yo creo que la
señora no aguantaba el antojo y se comía
mis milanesas
lo cual digo yo llegué a ese pensamiento
y dije bueno no hay problema está
perfecto entonces yo me podía poner a
hacer mi tarea y ya que se iba la señora
ésta iba al refri agarraba una leche
agarraba una caja de cereal me iba hacia
la sala ponía mi telenovela favorita que
el privilegio de amar y es y me convertí
serial y era muy feliz el resultado de
esto fue un niño de 78 años que entendió
la situación pero
supo adaptarse a ella para tener su
noche feliz y acabar su día felizmente
siguió la vida y hubo un momento también
que me enseñó bastante
en algún momento mi papá se desentendió
de nosotros tuvo sus razones y todo el
peso para sacarnos adelante cayó sobre
mi mamá las clases pusieron muy
difíciles al grado de que neta había
días que ni siquiera le alcanzaba para
darnos de comer entonces en esta
problemática mi mamá me propuso una
solución que va como perfecto como
estábamos en mi cuarto y me dijo mira la
solución es esta
te vas a tener que ir después de la
escuela a comer todos los días a la casa
de la amante de tu papá
daba de comer y te va a cuidar
a lo que le dije inmediatamente y yo era
un niño de nueve diez años que podría
decir bueno no entiende lo que es un
amante pero yo descubrí a esa amante y
no les voy a contar porque esa es otra
historia pero pero yo sabía lo que era
un amante no y no tenía problema porque
entendía que lo importante era comer y
no donde lo hiciera
la vida fue avanzando y mi mamá se fue
complicando más tenía problemas con el
papá había muchísimos problemas entonces
decidió que la mejor opción era todo
esto sucedió en cancún toda mi infancia
fue cancún y decidió que nos fuéramos a
vivir a la ciudad de méxico porque ahí
vivía mi abuelita y probablemente todo
iba a ser mejor y todo iba a estar como
más sencillo pero las cosas no fueron
así nosotros cambiamos para la ciudad de
mexico y mi mamá pues es una señora
grande que
no trabajaba en cancún o no sé se le
complicó mucho encontrar trabajo en una
nueva ciudad para ella fue difícil y
para mí también fue difícil porque tuve
que abandonar esta vida de niño fresa de
alguna forma porque yo estudiaba en la
salle en cancún tuve que abandonarla
rápidamente y entender mi nuevo estilo
de vida en un segundo
con un ejemplo yo en la escuela me
molestaban mucho de chiquito y me
acuerdo que yo estando en la salle y de
repente llegaban unos niños y me querían
molestar yo inmediatamente les decía si
se atreven a hacerme algo los voy a
acusar con los maestros ya no me hacía
nada
y en esta nueva vida en la leandro valle
en una escuela de gobierno
me acuerdo muy bien que en un recreo una
vez unos niños que empezaron con
adolescentes me empezaron a molestar me
agarraron de aquí y dije bueno vamos a
utilizar la misma carta antes de que me
hicieran algo les dije si se atreven a
hacerme algo nos voy a cruzar con los
maestros el resultado fue que me dieron
una paliza obviamente y lo pero entonces
que ni siquiera los acosa con los
maestros y no le dije a mi mamá porque
este pre adolescente de 12 años entendió
que ésta era la nueva vida y que éstas
eran las nuevas reglas y que tenía que
sobrevivir y salir adelante
nunca importado
con que disfrutar la vida era ese soy
ese niño que
si le das una piedrita y una rama va a
poder ser feliz durante horas puedo
disfrutar de todo porque no importaba si
se comían milanesas no importaba si me
molestaban en la escuela si tenía de
repente falta de atención y descuidos lo
que sea no importaba yo sabía que si o
si tenía que salir adelante me tenía que
adaptar si yo quería ser feliz
aprendí también a no depender
forzosamente de algo para poder ser
feliz
y a esa edad a partir de esa edad y
mientras fui creciendo aprendí que yo
soy responsable de mi vida y que nadie
nadie nadie tiene la culpa de lo malo
que me podría llegar a pasar
este ejemplo me gusta mucho utilizarlo
para poder explicar esta forma de
adaptación que he aprendido y es que
nadie quisiera tomar el camino más
difícil
nadie neta de todos los que estamos aquí
escuchando de los que puedan estar
viendo este vídeo nadie quisiera ir de
un punto de la ciudad a otro de la
manera más difícil
todos queremos llegar lo más rápido lo
más fácil económicamente no sé todos
queremos el camino más fácil para esto
y si tenemos la capacidad para la visión
para encontrar una ruta y hacerlo bien
creo que esto tendríamos que hacerlo en
cualquier situación que nos pasa en
nuestra vida pero porque podemos hacerlo
porque hacemos un análisis global de
todas las cosas sacamos nuestra
experiencia en transportes y pensamos si
tengo a mi disposición taxi y camión
micro teleférico bicicleta de caminar
saco todos esa posibilidad transportes y
a la vez me vuelvo un experto en
economía volteó a ver la cartera la
cuenta de banco y digo bueno está bien
todos los días me puedo ir en taxi al
trabajo oa la escuela donde quiera ir o
me tengo que ir en camión agarrar el
metro y caminar un poquito o me alcanza
para irme en metro y caminar mucho
se adaptarme porque me escuchó se
adaptarme porque sé disfrutar
yo disfruto de todos los detalles que
tiene la vida conmigo y lo puedo ver de
esta forma si alguien me pregunta cuál
ha sido uno de los mejores momentos de
tu vida fácilmente les puedo decir qué
fue ese estaba sentado en esa piedra
disfrutando del aire
para escuchar la música veía el mar veía
el verde de ese pasto el azul del cielo
las nubes disfrute de todos esos
pequeños detalles que de pronto ya ya no
vemos y creemos que no nos aporta nada
pero también se disfrutar las cosas más
complejas como gritar el gol de mexico
contra alemania en el mundial de rusia
puedo disfrutar los pequeños detalles
los grandes detalles que la vida tiene
conmigo
así como puedo disfrutar las tristezas
que eso para mí es fundamental porque si
me vuelven a preguntar otro de los
mejores momentos que has tenido en tu
vida les puedo decir que fue cuando
murió mi papá porque me entregué de
lleno a ese momento pude llorar le todo
lo que le tenía que llorar escribí de él
todo lo que tenía que escribir todos los
minutos estuvo en mi mente y todo eso
que le dedique y lo mucho que disfrute y
valore ese momento
se selló en mí y se yo todos sus buenos
recuerdos
y aprendía algo que la gente de repente
dice que no hay cosas para siempre y ahí
descubrí que a veces si hay cosas para
siempre el amor que le tengo a mi papá
va a ser para siempre
disfruto llorar con una película
disfruto cuando algo me conmueve estoy
leyendo
disfruto también cuando llegan esos
recuerdos en los momentos difíciles que
han pasado en mi vida
disfruto todo lo que lo que me ofrece
disfruto las tristezas mis amigos de
repente me dicen que voy a estar loco
como puedes disfrutar una tristeza y les
digo es que también la vida no nos da
momentos de extrema tristeza todos los
días y esos momentos están ahí para
enseñarnos algo y tenemos que aprender a
valorar los también dicen qué
que los días son buenos que todos los
días son buenos y la neta no todos los
días son buenos por más optimización muy
optimista y por más optimista que seas
no todos los días son buenos hay que
aprender que hay momentos que nos
rebasan hay tristezas hay pérdidas que
en verdad no podemos con ellas que hay
días en los que nuestra vida está tan
llena de problemas que no nos podemos
levantar de nuestra cama no podemos
salir de la casa tenemos miedo es
complicada la vida es complicada
me gusta metaforizar con esto y pensar
que la vida es como un
electrocardiograma ese aparatito que
está en los hospitales que va marcando
como el ritmo cardíaco
y qué es eso que la vida tiene momentos
buenos momentos malos momentos muy
arriba muy abajo mucha felicidad mucha
tristeza
y eso para mí creo que es la vida la
combinación y el equilibrio de todos
esos momentos
y creo que lo explica solo esos
movimientos significan que estamos vivos
y no hay que ser genios para saber qué
pasa si esos movimientos y esos momentos
se terminan
me sé adaptar porque me escuchó
porque disfruto de la vida
y porque también soy agradecido creo que
es fundamental que agradece que
agradezcamos a la vida todo lo que nos
da
agradezco agradezco haber despertado y
estar aquí con ustedes muchas veces
pensamos que pues si nos íbamos a
despertar al día siguiente no lo tenemos
como una obligación de vida y no
pensamos que es algo muy valioso poder
despertar poder seguir viviendo tener
contacto escuchar tantas historias se
nos olvida
agradezco una buena plática con mis
amigos y agradezco un buen café
agradezco
un ataque de ansiedad agradezco una
pelea con un hermano
agradezco un viaje por toda europa
en las ciudades más impresionantes pero
a la vez agradezco un viaje en el metro
con mis audífonos escuchando la canción
de ficción de golpe
le agradezco toda la vida y creo que
también por eso puedo adaptarme
por último me gustaría decirles que yo
sé que a veces no vemos la luz al final
del túnel
y que la vida es complicada y esa es su
esencia general
pero si tomamos el control de nuestras
vidas si acudimos al coraje a la fuerza
ya ya todo ese conocimiento necesario
realmente podemos lograr lo que sea
porque no hay pared que no puedas
derrumbar no hay camino que no puedas
cursar todos tienen un punto débil y hay
que encontrarlo
ríete cuando la vida te está tratando de
hacer reír pero también llora desgarra
te en llanto cuando te ofrece esos
momentos de vacío que te sofocan porque
esos momentos están ahí para enseñarte
algo no los ignores respeta a todos los
seres de este planeta piensa en los
demás no estamos solos
sé consciente amate lucha se raro
sueña
pero no sueñes tanto a veces siete horas
son suficientes
y después de todo lo que he dicho y al
final de cuentas puede ser que todos
estemos equivocados porque la vida es un
misterio gracias
[Aplausos]